[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
que se passe-t-il dans les quatre
régions ukrainiennes occupées ou
partiellement occupées par les Russes
c'est le dernier jour des référendums
organisés à l'est à doniès qu'à Louhans
et dans le sud dans les régions de
Carson et de zapporigia des simulacres
des pseudos référendum pour l'Ukraine et
ses alliés qui précèdent les annexions
par les Russes Moscou défendra ses
nouveautés territoires y compris avec
les armes nucléaires stratégiques
annoncées Medef numéro 2 du Conseil de
sécurité russe au moins deux explosions
sous-marins ont également été
enregistrés dans la Baltique avant les
fuites de North Stream qui relie la
Russie à l'Allemagne qui offre dénonce
de son côté une attaque terroriste
planifiée par Moscou les référendums ont
été annoncés au moment où Poutine a
décréter la mobilisation militaire
partielle après la contre-offensive
ukrainienne la contestation contre cette
mobilisation gronde en Russie les russes
continuent d'affluer vers la Géorgie et
Finlande mais aussi vers le Kazakhstan
le président casaque a d'ailleurs assuré
que son pays protégera les Russes qui
fuient vers son pays alors quelle est la
stratégie de Vladimir Poutine derrière
ses référendum derrière cette
mobilisation militaire partielle le
président russe est-il dans une fuite en
avant et en perd-il ses alliés Poutine
s'est-il préparé à passer d'une
opération spéciale à une guerre on en
débat avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés Oxanna microfanova
bonsoir à vous et bienvenue vous êtes
politologue enseignante chercheuse à
l'INALCO en face de vous Cyril Brett
bonsoir bienvenue également spécialiste
de relation internationales de la Russie
cofondateur du blog Eurasia prospective
et également mettre de conférences à
Sciences Po à Paris nous avons également
avec nous qui revoltons bonsoir
essayiste spécialiste des sociétés
communistes et postes communistes votre
dernier livre pensez le communisme et
sécher grâce à bienvenue à vous merci
d'être là nous avons en duplex 2 à
carquif en Ukraine Elena le Chine notre
envoyé spécial sur place en Ukraine
également notre ancienne correspondante
en Russie pour France 24 bonsoir Elena
[Musique]
la culture russe est à l'honneur dans ce
bureau de vote située en Sibérie ce qui
possède un passeport ukrainien sont
invités à participer au vote d'annexion
organisé par Moscou
après la Crimée annexée en 2014 s'est
référendum imposé concernent les
territoires occupés de doniesce et
lugangsk à l'est et de rerson et
zapporijah au sud au total 20% du
territoire ukrainien à Mario Paul
quelques habitants votent le visage
grave à quelques mètres de bâtiments
détruits par les frappes russes
asaporigia les habitants dénoncent
l'initiative russe
personnellement je ne crois pas que les
référendum est une base légale c'est
comme forcer les gens à dire quelque
chose tout en pointant une arme sur eux
les gens devraient décider eux-mêmes
quoi faire mais là vous êtes forcé
mais la Russie est bien déterminée à
mixer ses territoires et a même agité de
nouveau la menace nucléaire pour le
président Poutine il s'agit là de
protéger les populations
surtout ces territoires dans lesquels se
tient ce référendum et ton premier plan
et au centre de l'attention de notre
société et de tout le pays
du G7 ainsi que l'Union européenne ont
juré de ne jamais reconnaître les
résultats de ses références d'hommes et
ont promis des sanctions il leur a
conséquence à tous les personnes qui
sont qui participent dans cette dans
cette référenda illégale illégitime
la rappeler c'est référendum ne
changeront rien à la politique ou à
l'action militaire de l'Ukraine
on va écouter le chef de la diplomatie
ukrainienne
et l'essentiel est que ces actions
cette décision de Poutine
ne changeront rien à notre politique
de pour moi à notre diplomatie et à nos
actions sur le terrain militaire
à carquis et puis vous êtes notre
ancienne correspondante en Russie vous
connaissez bien le don basse c'est
référendum sont-ils pour citer un
article du Monde des élections à la
pointe du fusil
oui alors effectivement c'est une image
pour qu'on a tous en tête avec ces
soldats qui accompagnent les urnes vers
les habitants amenés à voter lors de ses
référendums je dirais qu'effectivement
je connais la situation dans les
territoires de Denise et de Laurence où
j'ai beaucoup travaillé je pense que
cette situation est très différente
aujourd'hui dans ce de Carson et de
zapporisia il faut bien comprendre que à
ces territoires de Donia est-ce que de
Laurence qu'ils ont deux facto été
occupés par la Russie depuis 2014 sans
que la Russie ne le reconnaisse ce n'est
que très récemment juste avant de lancer
la Grande Guerre le 24 février que
Vladimir Poutine a reconnu
l'indépendance même autoproclamée de ces
territoires avant de mener ces
référendums donc ça fait presque 8 ans
en fait que ces territoires vivent deux
facto sous
occupation russe ou lettre russe sans
que la Russie ne les ne les déclaré et
ce n'est que sur le tard aujourd'hui que
qu'il y a ses référendum dans les
territoires de
la situation est absolument différente
puisque il s'agit de territoire qui ont
été très fraîchement occupés par une
opération de grande guerre assumées par
la Russie c'est-à-dire d'invasion assumé
enfin presque assumé puisque Vladimir
Poutine n'a pas déclaré la guerre mais
l'opération spéciale de Denez efficace
de 2000 et de l'Ukraine enfin ça c'est
juste une question de terme mais il y a
une guerre très forte très violente très
immédiate au terme de laquelle on
s'était mise en place des autorités
collaborationnistes des autorités
d'occupation la plupart de des habitants
de ces régions ont fui ces territoires
et donc effectivement il y a eu toute
une technologie aussi de propagande qui
s'est mise en place dans ces territoires
avec là encore plus de façon encore plus
violente l'imposition de ces de ces
référendums en sachant que Vladimir
Poutine a à cœur de de procéder à ces
référendum le plus rapidement possible
pour ensuite dire que c'est le
territoire de la Russie ces régions là
et pour ensuite fonder quelque part son
mythe d'agression de l'Ukraine envers la
Russie puisqu'il aura rattaché ses
territoires occupés ces territoires
envahis en disant que puisque l'armée
ukrainienne avance vers ces territoires
qui ont eux-mêmes demandé à se détacher
de l'Ukraine et bien ça veut dire que
l'Ukraine attaque la Russie et donc cela
justifiera probablement la déclaration
d'une guerre par la suite Thierry volton
vous êtes d'accord c'est pour légitimer
en fait une annexion tout simplement que
l'admire Poutine qui manifestement c'est
exactement ce qui se passe c'est une
unité nation fausse une fausse
mitigation de la situation voilà ça va
changer beaucoup de choses et votre
correspondante a absolument raison de le
dire ce qui va changer c'est
effectivement tout le vocabulaire de
Moscou par rapport à ça puisque
effectivement si ces territoires sont
annexés du coup l'Ukraine va se trouver
dans le rang des agresseurs si je puis
dire vu de Moscou et donc ça va changer
sur les gens qui luttent contre ça parce
que et il faut faire très attention à ça
parce que du fait que ces territoires
vont être attachés à la Russie ceux qui
lutteront contre ça vont changer de
statut ce seront plus des soldats qui
éventuellement libérons ça viendra
touristes et c'est comme ça que Moscou
les jugera et en tant que tel en tant
que terroriste la statue changera et
donc leurs conditions changeront aussi
c'est-à-dire qu'on pourra éventuellement
inoubleront pas des des protections
guerrières habituelles etc puisque en
terroriste on peut faire ce que l'on
veut si je puis dire et mosquées ne sont
pas à mon avis donc ça va beaucoup
changer les choses avant alimenter la
propagande finalement de venir Poutine
et ça va changer aussi son
positionnement stratégique
bien sûr ça prépare tout ce que
tout ce qui a été dit ici puis ça va
changer aussi la façon dont il entrevoit
l'issue du conflit puisque
une version que je galérais fierai
presque d'optimiste qui est que bah il
empoche son gain il empêche sa victoire
il a rempli quelqu'un de quelques-uns
des objectifs stratégiques qu'il veut il
a il avance sa frontière à l'ouest sa
zone de contact avec l'OTAN n'est pas à
la frontière russe antérieure il peut
effectivement montrer qu'il a protégé
j'explique ça réteur et que je n'altère
pas qui protège les populations
où je pense comme c'est même le terme de
génocide qui est où le risque de
génocide qui est employé et puis il
montre il montre à l'OTAN puisqu'il se
considère désormais comme en guerre
contre l'OTAN qu'il a porté ses
positions plus loin et que c'est et
surtout que expositions sont désormais
un viobles au regard de sa propre
législation ok mais au regard également
de la menace nucléaire qui laisse peser
sur sur toute contre-offensive
ukrainienne ou contre toute initiative
occidentale pour reconstituer
l'intégrité territoriale de de l'Ukraine
et ça ça change beaucoup bien sûr ça
change beaucoup pour l'Ukraine qui donc
a un territoire mutilé ça change
beaucoup pour les occidentaux dans les
initiatives qui le peuvent prendre
puisque toute initiative qui prendront
sur ces quatre territoires dont
l'hétérogénéité a bien été rappelée sera
considéré comme une atteinte aux
intérêts nationaux russes directes donc
une agression contre les Russes
exactement
il faut les conflits le conflit continu
dans ces dans ces zones bien sûr on a vu
le chef de la diplomatie
ukrainienne très très déterminé donc sur
le terrain ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
la bataille par exemple du don-basse
elle est essentielle à divoly divers
zalinski elle pas terminé
elle n'a pas terminée moi aussi il faut
pas oublier un certain facteurs facteurs
de mobilisation parce que à l'issue de
ce référendum Poutine obtienne les
moyens le gosse selon lui de faire de
mobilisation de gens aussi au sud de
l'Ukraine voilà donc et c'est bien sûr
se représente une risque pour les hommes
de 18 jusqu'à 60 ans parce que il se
retrouve dans les situations qu'ils
peuvent être mobilisés par la force
tandis que la loi internationale le
droit est contre utilisation de
mobilisation dans le territoire qui sont
occupés soit sous l'élection ce facteur
il a encore une réserve au niveau de
population supplémentaires on ne voit
maintenant en Russie le processus de
mobilisation ne pas populaire du tout
par exemple il y a des Russes de Russes
qui veulent fuir en Géorgie qui veulent
fuir en Kazakhstan et pour remplacer de
soldats russes voilà il y a les
territoires qui sont
occupés suite
ce n'est pas simple qui rigole pour mais
comment est-ce que ça va être organisé
sur place c'est une fois que les voilà
les référendum ont clairement c'est 96 %
de oui maintenant comment ça fonctionne
il va instaurer l'ordre poutinien si je
puis dire d'une façon claire avec la loi
russe avec évidemment les lois sur les
mobilisations des des soldats toutes les
lois répressives qui ont été prises en
compte contre les déserteurs etc tout ça
va s'appliquer sur ce territoire là
maintenant en tant que loi russe et donc
ça changera énormément de choses
évidemment pour pour les pour ces
territoires
occupés pour ces pauvres Ukrainiens qui
seront occupés en vérité qui sont
intégrés digérés si je puis dire par la
Russie Elena alors c'est évidemment on
voit que ça justifie encore sa
historique sur le nucléaire Vladimir
Poutine on entend du Mitry Medvedev vous
me disiez d'ailleurs un peu plus tôt que
il y a cette rhétorique du nucléaire qui
est quand même très présente à carquif
en Ukraine on en parle beaucoup
oui c'est une vraie peur qui est là
effectivement puisque il faut savoir que
aussi que dans la doctrine nucléaire
russe qui a été la nouvelle doctrine qui
a été adoptée il y a 2 ou 3 ans je crois
et bien le il est prévu que la Russie
puisse utiliser l'arme nucléaire en cas
de menace existentielle pour pour son
territoire enfin en cas de menace pour
son existence donc à partir de ce moment
là si l'on écoute attentivement la
rhétorique de Vladimir Poutine qui est
de dire que la Russie est menacée depuis
le début d'ailleurs de cette guerre
c'est comme ça qu'il a justifié son
opération spéciale j'étais de dire que
c'était un peu le mythe de l'agression
préventive si vous voulez même s'il la
présenter carrément comme une défense en
train de dire que si la Russie n'était
pas allée des nazifiés des militariser
l'Ukraine et bien c'est la Russie qui
serait aujourd'hui sous les bombes de
l'OTAN de l'Occident collectif comme
comme la Russie appelle les pays
occidentaux qui soi-disant mènentaient
une guerre contre la Russie à travers le
proxy ukrainien donc effectivement si on
écoute toute cette rhétorique
mythologique à justifier à qui a servi à
justifier l'agression de l'Ukraine on
pourrait penser que c'est une
préparation à l'emploi de d'une arme
d'une arme nucléaire après tactique
ponctuelle locale enfin ça on peut on
peut juste attendre de voir quel sera le
scénario mais effectivement c'est une
menace qui en tout cas ici en Ukraine
d'autant plus dans ces régions déjà en
guerre et prise très au sérieux à
carquif donc vous êtes c'est incroyable
ce que dit Elena verochine parce
qu'effectivement sur place on se rend
compte que la menace elle est vraiment
forte là on voit que l'OTAN vient de
répondre à la Russie en disant que si
jamais il y avait utilisation d'armes
nucléaires par la Russie ça serait
considéré comme inacceptable par l'OTAN
et que ça aurait des conséquences
sévères donc là on est vraiment dans une
escalade encore pousser un peu plus loin
avec ces référendums
oui on fera on franchit des étapes et
qui sont étroitement liés les unes aux
autres la mobilisation évidemment
puisque l'effort de guerre russes a
besoin de trop
laisser référendum dont on ne rappellera
jamais assez qu'ils sont parfaitement
illégaux l'annexion probable de ces
quatre de mascara la protection la
protection du parapluie nucléaire russe
rappelé à plusieurs reprises et en
matière de de dissuasion nucléaire la
répétition est à elle seule extrêmement
extrêmement
significative et puis
ce dont on va parler vraisemblablement
le sort de ces gazoducs en mer Baltique
situation très difficile à analyser
un bon contexte des conséquences c'est
très clair
c'est un des axes majeurs
d'approvisionnement de l'Europe par la
Russie qui est manifestement endommagé
et qui risque de excusez-moi d'après ce
que j'ai compris juste un le contexte
qu'on comprenne on a entendu donc il y a
eu au moins deux explosions sous-marines
qui ont été enregistrés dans la Baltique
justement avant les fuites vous allez
voir la carte de Nord Stream qui relie à
on le sait ce gazoduc de la Russie à
l'Allemagne ils auront donc été touché
il y a eu des fuites en mer Baltique et
manifestement il s'agirait donc
d'explosion alors qui est dénonce une
attaque terroriste planifiée par Moscou
je cite là-bas les autorités d'ailleurs
suédoises parle éventuellement évoque
éventuellement un sabotage la Maison
Blanche a déjà dit qu'elle serait prête
à soutenir les Européens Thierry volton
là c'est encore une nouvelle fois une
escalade avec l'utilisation d'autres
types d'armes oui si c'est le cas bien
sûr c'est exactement on avance à chaque
fois un pion supplémentaire ça c'est
clair maintenant je sais pas parce que
j'ai pas ce que j'ai entendu mais je
parce que je sais c'est est-ce que c'est
nursrine un stream 2 qui a été parce que
nous deux n'est pas en fonction non ce
serait North stream
d'approvisionnement ce qui se passe de
l'Allemagne qui en cause donc ça
complique la situation pour l'Europe
soyons clairs et puis c'est vrai que ça
met une tension en plus supplémentaire
alors moi personnellement je ne vois pas
à l'heure qu'il est qui aurait intérêt à
vraiment faire ça sauf éventuellement
les Russes pour faire monter encore un
peu plus attention mais encore que bon
pour l'instant je crois qu'on a en
rester à mon avis ou qu'on prudemment
rester au congés lecture
ce sont les Russes il faut
et il faut quand même rappeler que les
guerres de gosse c'est pas quelque chose
souvent on a déjà la Russie déjà utilisé
cette moyenne le garde des gaz Russie
ukrainien c'est connu c'est 2008 2009
quand la Russie a fermé le robinet en
plein hiver et elle a essayé voir des
conséquences mais sauf que le chat le
plus petit il s'agit de la Russie et de
l'Ukraine en ce moment-là le crâne a
trouvé la solution tout simplement on a
fait la position des rêves sur les
réseaux Duke et comme ça le crâne était
capable de réchauffer le prix mais je
pense que c'était déjà une petite
explication aux Européens c'est que pour
les atteindre l'avenir si les Russes ont
commencé déjà utilisé cette larme de gaz
au passé pourquoi pas contenir mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'il le revendiquerait
pas après tout pour l'instant les Russie
c'est tout
on l'apprendra mais je pense pas qu'ils
vont là ils ont intérêt à revendiquer
parce que c'est leur structure c'est la
même enfin vous me direz au point ils en
sont ils ont pas besoin d'aller aux
bornes de l'Europe encore un peu plus
donc moi je ne vois pas enfin je vois
l'intérêt évidemment et vous avez raison
je vois l'intérêt de si on attaque le
gazoduc qui qui approvisionne l'Europe
on prive encore plus l'Europe de gaz
mais vous savez que c'est quand même été
considérablement restreintes l'arrivée
de gaz et il était question justement
que jusqu'à la fin de l'année les
Allemands qui sont particulièrement
dépendants restaient encore leur demande
donc il y avait alors est-ce que ça va
être interrompu lorsqu'il va à cause de
l'attentat à ce moment-là ça va poser
des vrais problèmes très graves à
l'Allemagne soyons clairs
ah oui les conséquences là sont
extrêmement fortes pour la pour
l'approvisionnement en énergie des
industriellement et donc pour la
prospérité européenne c'est une c'est
une mauvaise nouvelle à court terme à
moyen terme c'est sans doute une très
bonne nouvelle ça veut donc dire que la
diversification des approvisionnements
énergétiques et tout particulièrement
fossiles pour l'Europe va être encore
plus prononcé et encore plus rapide la
conséquence d'un point de vue
stratégique et simplement descriptif
c'est donc l'Europe d'un côté et la
Russie de l'autre
sont en train de s'éloigner à une
vitesse encore plus prononcée du fait de
la rupture de ce de ce gazoduc qui peut
être rappelons-le n'est pas le seul
gazoduc qui alimente l'Europe en
hydrocarbures en hydrocarbure russe
c'est un des principaux un des plus
emblématiques mais ce n'est pas le seul
et là qui passera reçu de il y en a qui
il y en a un qui passe par le sud donc
plus ancien alors ces référendum dont on
parlait il y a un instant ont été
annoncés au moment où Vladimir Poutine a
décrété vous le savez cette mobilisation
militaire
réservistes depuis de nombreux Russes
fuient et la contestation gronde en
Russie vous allez voir ces images qui
ont été filmées aujourd'hui même à la
frontière en Géorgie la frontière
géorgienne les ai également au
Kazakhstan il y a des fils de voiture
elles sont aussi visibles d'ailleurs aux
frontières finlandaises la Géorgie a
fait état de 10000 Russes qui
franchissent la frontière chaque jour
depuis l'annonce de la mobilisation et
le Kazakhstan lui fait état de 98
000 citoyens russes qui sont arrivés
depuis cette mobilisation l'afflux est
également observée donc à la frontière
de la Mongolie de la Finlande on va
écouter ce qu'on n'a pas les images en
tout cas on va écouter les réactions de
ces russes qui se sont arrêtées devant
les frontières géorgiennes on les écoute
notre président après avoir déclaré la
guerre à un état voisin après avoir
annexé illégitimement une partie de son
territoire tente maintenant d'entraîner
la population dans cette guerre
fratricide
j'ai peur d'être mobilisé parce que j'ai
des qualifications militaires j'ai un
grade d'officier j'ai servi dans l'armée
russe donc je suis en première ligne
mais je ne suis pas d'accord avec cette
mobilisation je ne peux pas aller là-bas
et tuer ces gens que j'ai aidés on va
peut-être les voir ces images parce que
c'est vrai que c'est assez
impressionnant Elena vous qui connaissez
très bien la propagande russe pourquoi
est-ce qu'elle ne fait pas mouche
pourquoi est-ce que dans ce cas elle ne
réussit pas à mobiliser finalement les
Russes
mais parce que cette ce soutien fictif à
l'opération militaire spéciale de
Vladimir Poutine c'était comme le disent
les opposants une guerre du divan une
guerre du canapé c'est-à-dire que
c'était des gens qui regardaient leur
télévision et qui disaient oui à
l'opération spéciale oui à la
délivification nous sommes pour la paix
il n'y a que l'opération spéciale qui
pourra ramener la paix en Russie dans le
monde russe et nous verrons tous comme
des frères avec nos Ukrainiens qui nous
diront merci de les avoir libéré des
nazis donc si vous voulez ça c'était la
façade cette espèce de bulle d'opinion
publique complètement fictive qu'avaient
créé la propagande sauf que au jour
d'aujourd'hui et bien la guerre a
explosé au nez et à la phase des Russes
elle s'est invitée chez eux
littéralement avec ses paviestes qui
c'est c'est bulletins de mobilisation
avec cette mobilisation qui est
d'ailleurs bien au-delà de la
mobilisation partielle enfin on voit
qu'on sait que c'est totalement
arbitraire qu'il y a eu des gens qui
mobilisables qui ne le sont pas selon
les règles adoptées par ce décret qu'il
y a des gens qui ne sont pas du tout
mobilisables réservistes voire même des
handicapés des gens qui n'ont jamais
qui n'ont rien à voir avec avec la
réserve qui sont mobilisées il y a des
dans certaines régions il y a des rafles
qui ressemblent presque à une
mobilisation générale donc on voit le
côté arbitraire donc c'est vraiment la
guerre qui s'est invitée chez les ruches
chez eux moi je garde en tête toujours
cette image où j'étais au tout début de
la guerre à 15 km 20 km de la frontière
de l'autre côté en Russie de là où je
suis maintenant à côté du côté de
Belgorod et on avait des chasseurs qui
passaient dans le ciel cette guerre
venait de commencer lucrètes les
chasseurs russes allaient bombarder
l'Ukraine et à l'hôtel où je me trouvais
il y avait une soirée une discothèque
avec pardon c'était à 130 km déjà
j'étais un remonté un petit peu plus au
nord mais enfin on était quand même un
peu plus de 100 km de la frontière à
course et il y avait dans cet hôtel une
discothèque quelqu'un qui fêtait un
anniversaire et je suis allé voir le
réceptionniste en lui disant mais c'est
quand même terrible il me dit mais
qu'est-ce qui est terrible je dis mais
le pays est en guerre il me dit mais
quelle guerre il n'y a pas de guerre
vous voyez donc c'est vous dire au
lendemain de la déclaration de
l'opération militaire spécial c'est à
dire que la Russie vivez dans une
réalité il vit tout vivait dans une
réalité parallèle jusqu'à l'annonce de
cette mobilisation c'est d'ailleurs pour
cela que Vladimir Poutine attardé à à
prendre cette mesure puisque il l'a fait
parce qu'il est en train de perdre ici
dans la région où je me trouve les
Ukrainiens ont regagné et continuent de
regagner des milliers de kilomètres
carrés de leur territoire c'est une
débat que une hécatombe pour l'armée
russe et pour les mercenaires et pour
les bénévoles et pour toutes les
formations qui combattent côté russe et
donc y compris pour les proxy de la DNR
et de la de la LNR les combattants
locaux dont on nous dit qu'ils sont
particulièrement cruels envers les
civils et avec cette débâcle avec ces
hécatombe et bien Vladimir Poutine n'a
pas eu d'autre choix que de mobiliser le
plus possible moi je pense
personnellement que le chiffre de 300
000 c'était juste pour donner un chiffre
et qu'en réalité les mobiliser les
mobilisables il y en aura tout ce que en
fait la Russie peut finalement mobiliser
pour les envoyer envahir envahir
l'Ukraine et donc effectivement là c'est
l'horreur c'est la concernation c'est la
panique en Russie vous voyez tous ces
gens qui essaient de fuir alors à
l'intérieur de ces gens il y a
différentes tranches d'opinions il y a
ceux qui étaient passivement contre la
guerre mais qui se disait qu'ils
allaient tout de même rester en Russie
je connais aussi des gens qui étaient
sortis au tout début par justement par
cette peur de la mobilisation et puis
finalement qui sont revenus en se disant
mais non ça n'aura pas lieu donc en fait
il y a des gens aussi bien en Russie et
en Ukraine qui voient se réaliser leur
pire cauchemar c'est pour ça que en fait
nous vu d'ici on peut envisager les
pires scénarios on envisage les pires
scénarios parce que vu de loin on a
l'impression que le pire on n'arrivera
jamais mais vu du côté ukrainien comme
du côté russe maintenant aujourd'hui on
voit on voit les pires les pires
scénarios se réaliser et donc
aujourd'hui effectivement les Russes
tentent tant bien que mal de fuir mais
en fait il y a aussi une fermeture
partielle des frontières on voit
beaucoup d'hommes qui sont empêchés
maintenant de sortir ça devient de plus
en plus difficile un petit révoltant à
ce que les Russes comme le décrit Elena
sont un peu sortis une sorte d'apathie
dans laquelle il se trouvait et que
Poutine est sorti j'ai lu d'une sorte de
contrat qu'il avait avec sa population
c'est on gère l'état on fait une
opération spéciale mais on vous laisse
tranquille grosso modo c'est un peu cher
que ce soit vraiment comme ça que ça se
passe enfin bon admettons cette
dichotomie bon c'est évident que
d'autant plus c'est d'autant plus
préoccupant parce qu'on ne sait pas
c'est qu'il y a un article dans la
mobilisation ce qu'on appelle l'article
7 dans lequel n'est pas donné de nom de
chiffre exactement de mobilisation ça a
été donné 300000 mais peuvent très bien
rappeler un million de personnes s'ils
veulent donc ça peut toucher beaucoup
plus de monde que ça alors ce qui est
intéressant ce qui est amusant pour un
historien comme moi si je puis dire de
cette situation amusant triste
tristement amusant c'est que ça va pas
une période où il y avait des rideaux de
fer et ou même en Vietnam ou ailleurs
quand il est régime communiste les gens
fuyaient aussi et donc on disait qu'il
votait avec leurs pieds et je pense que
là ce cette fuite a raison de la guerre
est un moyen c'est une vision c'est une
ça nous permet de comprendre à quel
point ce régime est en vérité un bon on
le sait bien sûr mais en vérité un
régime de force dans lequel qui repose
pas forcément sur un consensus populaire
sans doute en tout cas dans les
campagnes dans certaines campagnes mais
certains campagnes de façon générale et
de futurs de possibles
soldats en est une preuve accablante
pour les régimes
okskrainien a dit que il allait leur
donner la clémence enfin bref qui ne
serait pas arrêté si jamais
effectivement il se retrouve en Ukraine
enfin il essaye de les accueillir plus
ou moins
oui bien sûr le président ski il a
annoncé qu'il y a une solution pour pour
des Rousses qui se trouvent mobilisés
contre le désir c'est-à-dire les
possibilités de se rendre tout
simplement c'est possible de se rendre
et c'est l'indiquer souligne qui est
quand même le crâne respecte la loi de
Genève et il peut être acquis dans on
peut dire dans les conditions correctes
aussi il comprend bien pour le situation
qui est certain soldats peuvent avoir
peur de fait qu'elle s'est rendu dans
Zelinski il est dit que on ne va pas du
tout avoir la partie russe qui était
selon leur propre voilà et aussi il est
dit qu'il y a éventuellement un peu
sécher le troisième probabilité que
certains russes tout simplement se
retrouver en Ukraine ils veulent plus
revenir en Russie parce que ils ont peur
de régime et il a dit que c'est
difficile qu'on a vu là c'est donc
cette possibilité c'est aussi
envisageable pour les ukrainiens et
surtout on conseille aux soldats bonsoir
soit disant le soldat russe qui parce
que non pas voulu du tout être le soldat
de cette possibilité de se rendre sur
une option tout simplement pour sauver
leur vie est-ce que ça veut dire que la
meilleure poutine est vraiment aux abois
quand effectivement immobilise comme ça
je dirais dans une espèce de chaos quoi
tout tout ressemble un peu à au cas où
depuis c'est un signe de faiblesse pas
tant on s'est souvent demandé on se
demande traditionnellement si la
Fédération de Russie a les moyens de un
projet de puissance et de ses ambitions
militaires et stratégiques on voit qu'il
y a une des ressources absolument
essentielles aussi bien d'un point de
vue militaire que sur les autres points
qui est la population
cette cette fuite montre que le soutien
de la population est je dirais
chancelant et je suis très en dessous de
la réalité vraisemblablement et que ce
qui constitue la matière première de
toute ambition militaire les troupes
font cruellement défauts donc aux abois
il faut avoir des éléments internes sur
les rapports de force que dont je
dispose pas là en tout cas c'est un des
signes de faiblesse les plus patents
qu'on ait eu après l'échec de
l'offensive des premières semaines vers
Kef sauf niveau moi aussi je le disais
l'armée russe est entraînée à guéri
puissante bien armée elle n'a pas pris
la capitale et fort heureusement pas
limogé le gouvernement là c'est vraiment
je pense
avec la contre-offensive dont on est
dont elle est la conséquence directe un
aveu de faiblesse sur le terrain qui est
qui est patant incontestable et
d'ailleurs les médias rusques suit ici
ne sont pas particulièrement divers sur
les raisons de cette fuite et sur la
difficulté
donc le service de renseignement russe a
dit de lui-même qu'il y a 250 000 hommes
qui ont fui pourquoi les fesses B l'a
dit je n'avoue que j'ai pas la réponse à
ça en tout cas ce que je voudrais dire
par rapport à ces gens qui fuient c'est
que on se rend pas compte parce que nous
on est dans bien confortablement
installé ici dans un studio parisien etc
mais fuir son pays c'est pas rien on
abandonne tous ses amis sa famille son
logement etc bon d'une part et d'autre
part ils se mettent complètement hors la
loi alors vous me direz au point ils en
sont ils n'ont pas le choix c'est un
crime pénal puni de 10 ans donc ça
rappelle d'ailleurs les excusez-moi ça
rappelle les méthodes staliniennes
puisque comme vous le savez les Staline
ne reconnaissait pas des soldats
prisonniers et d'ailleurs les
prisonniers pendant la guerre russe
n'avaient recevaient aucun colis c'était
les seuls prisonniers de la guerre qui
n'en savaient pas de colis donc là on
est on est à peu près on a retrouvé à
peu près le langage au saheliens
puisqu'il y a une loi qui vient de
tomber comme quoi toute personne qui se
qui ne pas qui se rend envahir c'est pas
ça qui qui ne répond pas au combat sans
autorisation il y a marqué sans
autorisation et passible de 10 ans de
prison donc vous voyez on punit
terriblement ces gens-là donc moi je
pense que notre devoir si nous avions un
devoir avoir en tant que pays libre et
démocratique c'est que je pense qu'il
faudrait quand même aider ces gens qui
vont qui sont en train de fuir parce que
encore une fois il perdent tout et alors
je comprends qu'il peut y avoir des
provocateurs etc j'entends bien tout ça
je suis pas innocent non plus mais quand
même je pense que notre devoir serait
d'essayer d'accueillir ces gens-là et je
pense pas fermer les frontières en tout
cas pareil pour les Ukrainiens il faut
pas le faire pour se déserteurs
l'Allemagne se dit prête à accueillir
les déserteurs et la Commission
européenne appelle les 27 à définir une
position commune qui justement
s'agissant de ces russes qui filent leur
pays donc on attend ce type de position
pour l'instant on a eu la position en
tout cas du président casaque qui est
tout de même un des alliés
de Poutine proche et bien lui a dit
qu'il allait protéger les Russes qui
fuient vers le Kazakhstan et on a vu
qu'il y en a un certain nombre presque
100 000 on va l'écouter
il y a une guerre d'ampleur qui se
déroule dans notre voisinage immédiat
nous devons nous en souvenir en pensant
avant tout à notre sécurité
l'intégrité territoriale d'un État doit
être inaliénable c'est un principe clé
j'en ai toujours parlé ouvertement et
clairement sur la scène internationale
Elena vous êtes toujours à carquif moi
je me souviens que vous pouvez vous
étiez justement au Kazakhstan au moment
où Vladimir Poutine est allé aider son
meilleur allié il n'y a pas si longtemps
au moment où il y avait des populations
dans la rue et bien aujourd'hui on peut
dire que il y a le président Casa que
c'est désolidarise de la lumière Poutine
il lâche un peu son allié
oui ça c'est effectivement assez
important et assez significatif parce
qu'effectivement en janvier lorsqu'il y
a eu ces mouvements de protestation
violemment réprimées d'ailleurs avec
l'aide des forces dites de maintien de
la paix de l'Organisation du Traité de
sécurité collectif emmené par la Russie
et bien à ce moment-là on disait que
effectivement Vladimir Poutine est cassé
que je marque au Cayenne était vraiment
alliés et que tokaya fait même passer un
pacte avec Vladimir Poutine pour obtenir
sa protection et pour et pour ensuite
mener une alliance géostratégique mais
effectivement aujourd'hui on voit que ni
le Kazakhstan ni d'ailleurs même la
Chine dans une certaine mesure sont
vraiment solidaires et et adoptent cette
rhétorique propagandiste de Vladimir
Poutine qui est de dire que les pays non
alignés doivent défendre leur
souveraineté parce que c'est pas
seulement un discours vis-à-vis des
nazis Ukrainiens si vous voulez qu'elle
a réussi c'est aussi vis-à-vis de tout
l'Occident et Vladimir Poutine cherchent
de plus en plus à créer une coalition de
pays non alignés
derrière lui pour dire que dans cette
guerre on combat aussi l'hégémonie
occidentale il s'agit de restaurer un
ordre multipolaire etc c'est un peu tout
ce qu'on entend depuis son fameux
discours de Munich qui aujourd'hui est
répété quasiment toutes les semaines par
Vladimir Poutine alors qu'on se souvient
qu'à l'époque avec créer une onde de
choc on se disait mais pourquoi Vladimir
Poutine tient des propos aussi durs donc
tout ça aussi pour te dire pour dire que
effectivement aujourd'hui même ces
pays-là qu'on attendait à ses côtés ne
sont pas dans le soutien donc Vladimir
Poutine est de plus en plus quoi qu'il
en dise isolé de plus en plus acculé
donc il va falloir un moment donné qu'il
manœuvre seul en durcissant la
répression autant que possible à
l'intérieur de son pays parce qu'on voit
effectivement ces vagues de protestation
aujourd'hui notamment par exemple dans
la région caucésienne du Daguestan qui
sont absolument sans précédent cette
mobilisation aussi et sans précédent en
me disant que il fallait en arriver là
pour qu'il y ait ce genre de
protestation alors que le contexte de
répression et de censure c'est durci
comme jamais en Russie Cyril Brett le
président biélorus aussi est un petit
peu timoré il n'a pas tellement envie
d'envoyer les Biélorusses sur le avons
aussi donc ça va vraiment dans le sens
de ce que vient de dire Elena donc il y
aura peut-être encore plus de répression
en Russie mais ces alliés y compris les
alliés naturels si je puis dire le lâche
c'est un des c'est un des véritables
pivots stratégiques de cette de cette
guerre l'isolement de la réussite qu'on
pressentait qu'on annonçait que certains
regrettaient ou certains se
réjouissaient est en train de se
manifester et il est en train de se
manifester avec vous avez cité
Biélorussie Kazakhstan Chine si cette
pays-là ne soutiennent pas comme ils
l'ont fait durant les deux dernières
décennies la Fédération de Russie
effectivement elle est à redoutée que ce
sera un mouvement de répression interne
qui sera destiné à compenser cet
isolement pourquoi est-ce qu'il ne le
soutiennent pas finalement le président
casaque
je pense que en dépit du de
l'intervention russe enfin de
l'Organisation du Traité de sécurité
collective au Kazakhstan le Kazakhstan
reprend le chemin de sa diplomatie
depuis son indépendance qui était
d'avoir une position équilibrée certains
diraient à une position focus mais une
position équilibrée c'est à dire de
l'intérêt convergent et de coopération
convergentes avec la Russie et d'intérêt
convergent avec l'Occident il en va de
même aussi de la Biélorussie dont on a
fait trop rapidement après la répression
des élections qui sont truquées un
Faisal absolu de la Russie qui avait
toujours ménagé une espèce de double jeu
quant à la Chine elle va tirer avantage
de la position de faiblesse de la Russie
pour obtenir des concessions de la part
de la région on va pas plaindre le
régime de Vladimir Poutine mais ce qui
est sûr c'est classe c'est un
affaiblissement des trois principaux si
ce n'est soutiens du moins partenaire
avec lequel
plus l'un qui est resté traîné jusqu'à
maintenant oui mais qui est en train de
pencher c'est très important dans
l'équilibre des forces bon donc il est
mal parti si je puisse il est mal parti
mais Oxana il est trop fanova il est mal
parti mais est-ce que finalement il est
quand même dans une fuite en avant plus
de répression clairement en Russie une
mobilisation générale du chantage aux
nucléaire maintenant il y a ces
explosions
dans les gazoducs de Nord Stream est-ce
qu'il est dans une fuite en avant
Vladimir Poutine
c'est difficile à définir si
concrètement parce que quand même on a
eu une contrainte ukrainienne et le
crâne c'est clair et net que référendum
ça change rien mais le problème que
c'est l'évêque et avec les verres les
conditions de vie des ukrainiennes
peuvent être aussi très difficiles et
comme pour les Européens suite par
exemple de russes sur l'enfance
structure et logistique ensuite on ne
peut pas appeler ma prévoir la réaction
suivante de Poutine est-ce qu'il va
utiliser
le pratique quand même par exemple cette
question
moi je vous propose de regarder cette
question ne pas de vue quand même
pratique en France maintenant elle se
trouve à peu près récente 100 000 de
réfugiés ukrainien le polo la Pologne
c'est peut-être 2 millions et je
souligne qui est en Pologne
75% de réfugieuses sont logés dans les
maisons de Polonais donc je voudrais
bien poser les questions est-ce que les
Français les Polonais sont prêts à
accueillir dans la maison le désordre je
sais pas du tout la réponse de la part
des Français mais je connais un peu la
même qualité de Polonais et je pense pas
qu'elles sont prêtes à écrire 75 dans
leur maison et pourquoi
ce sont des femmes avec des enfants de
principalement et c'est pour la
mentalité de Polonais c'est très
important que les hommes craignent
restent quand même faire la guerre et
protéger sa propre patrie et le polonais
qui est plutôt les femmes les enfants et
les hommes bien âgés qui ont handicapés
qui peuvent plus faire la guerre et
accueillir les auteurs les hommes Russes
et les Polonais qui c'est assez
considérable quand même qui sont très
justifiés d'ailleurs en tout cas en
Occident ils continuaient à avoir cette
solidarité donc on parlait de l'Europe
qui va peut-être prendre une décision
commune sur cette question des
déserteurs russes et puis Catherine
Colonna donc à la chef de la diplomatie
française qui était à Kiev aujourd'hui
on va l'écouter
pour le moment ce qui nous occupe le
plus c'est la tenue des pseudos
référendum des simulacres de référendum
dans des régions qui sont sous
occupation militaire et sans doute par
la manière forte donc ces référendums ne
sont pas de vrais référendum ils n'ont
aucune validité aucune légitimité aucune
légalité il y aura de nouvelles
sanctions nous l'avons annoncé nous le
ferons et nous introduisons au Conseil
de sécurité une résolution pour dire que
ces référendums sont nuls et non avenue
n'ont aucune valeur et sont une nouvelle
fois des actes de provocation qui sont
pas du tout nécessaires on a mis cette
interviewée par Gulliver Craig à notre
correspondant dans la région plus de
sanctions Cyril Brett donc c'est ça
aussi escalade ah oui c'est absolument
essentiel on ne peut pas laisser passer
une nouvelle annexion d'une partie
considérable du territoire ukrainien
sans prendre des mesures qui dans
l'ordre symbolique dans l'ordre
politique dans l'ordre économique et
dans l'ordre sécurité ne marque pas le
refus absolu de l'Union européenne de de
ces référendum et je vois deux
directions qui vont être à coup surprise
par l'Union européenne à l'unanimité il
faut toujours le rappeler évidemment un
élargissement de la liste des personnes
qui vont être sanctionnées je pense que
ça va s'élargir à des responsables
civiles juristes administrateurs qui ont
concouru à organiser ces pseudos
référendum et un élargissement également
des secteurs économiques dans lesquels
la Russie va être privée d'échanges avec
l'ouest dans des domaines qui ne seront
plus strictement stratégiques ou
militaires mais également civil donc là
le ce que va faire l'Union européenne
est parfaitement conforme à la stratégie
de sanction qu'elle a adopté contre la
Russie depuis près de 10 ans maintenant
contre la Biélorussie également depuis
plusieurs années elle fait sentir
d'abord elle marque avant même de
s'interroger sur l'efficacité des
sanctions elle marque son désaccords de
principe avec ses référendums et c'est
déjà essentiel et ensuite les
conséquences vont se manifester
notamment la dégradation à terme à moyen
terme de la situation économique et
sociale en Russie on ne connaît pas
encore l'impact des sanctions
le printemps va être difficile en Russie
et même l'hiver va être difficile aussi
pour plein de choses donc il faut pas
désespérer dans le sens où il y a tout
un discours qui dit nous sommes plus
victime des sanctions que les c'est un
discours de défaitiste si je puis dire
quelque part bon et donc en vérité là
aussi est touché au cœur de son système
économique alors évidemment c'est très
lent parce que d'abord à la des
richesses elle a de l'argent elle a bon
elle a des raisons
à la réserves considérable bon voilà
donc ça va ça va presque tendance à dire
raisonnement à contrario qu'est-ce qu'on
dirait de la position de l'Union
européenne si elle n'a adoptait pas ses
sanctions face à des ces référendum et
puis ces annexions enfin ce serait
absolument inacceptable
mais aussi son groupe de gendarmes les
guistres Français qui sont encore
je veux personnellement remercier la
France pour cette action je trouve que
c'est très important que c'est la France
qui se trouve avec le crâne dans ce
domaine de découverte de crime de guerre
et donc je suis sûr que les gens de
cette profession de gendarme l'église
ils sont débuts sont au courant c'est
que se passe parce que ils étaient à
bout de chat ils ont découvertes de
guerre qui était commis demain il repart
à usine c'est exactement c'est les
Français les gendarmes français qui qui
commence
leur travail là-bas et malheureusement
je pense que malheureusement c'est je
pense que c'est pas le dernier visite de
ce groupe et plus tard quand les
territoires ont coupé qui sont
maintenant
occupés selon le béret je pense que ce
groupe reviendra et on va avoir encore
des découvert très sombres donc du coup
le gouvernement français je pense que
c'est parmi le premier gouvernement du
monde qui est très bien informé des
crimes de guerre qui était en Ukraine et
aboutia maintenant isium et plus tard
dans les autres
aussi peut-être je considère que suite à
ça le politique française échange
échanger et on a des relations plus
proches de l'Ukraine avec la France et
déjà aujourd'hui que le bas il est
annoncé que il a parlé aussi de canon de
César avec ministre un peu basculer de
l'autre côté justement plus proche des
Ukrainiens parce que Emmanuel Macron dit
qu'il parle trop à venir Poutine d'abord
il s'est rendu qu'une seule fois de son
de plusieurs fois Boris Johnson s'est
rendu trois fois au moins donc bon je
suis très content que Madame Colonna
c'est ait été à Kiev aujourd'hui mais
madame vandenayenne il y a télé au moins
deux fois ou trois fois donc on est
quand même très en retrait par rapport à
nos alliés bon et vous voyez des canons
César tout à l'heure on sait très bien
qu'il y a eu très peu qui ont été livrés
il faut dire qu'on en a pas beaucoup bon
donc ceci explique ici cela bon mais
mais quand même donc au niveau de
l'armement au niveau de de de de de
l'engagement même diplomatique la France
est un tout petit peu en retrait par
rapport à ses alliés ne parlons pas les
Américains qui sont à la pointe bien sûr
elle devrait faire plus si elle Brette
la France non je partage pas ce je
partage pas cette cette façon de voir
les choses il faut le voir sur le long
terme il faut non seulement évidemment
l'aide militaire mais aussi de
budgétaire et les diplomatique que la
France a fourni sans faillir depuis le
début à l'Ukraine on peut toujours faire
plus quand il s'agit de procéder des
civils c'est sûr mais je pense pas qu'on
puisse critiquer la France sur ce
point-là c'est déjà désir quand on
visite madame colonas il ne s'agit pas
de première visite c'est déjà le
deuxième point quand c'est il se rendra
Kia et le premier visite aussi c'était
très important parce que exactement
pendant la première visite madame
Colonna a éclairé la position de la
France à propos de l'aider de communauté
de politique qui a voulu ou créer
Emmanuel Macron parce que au début on
Ukraine on a pris cette dernière parce
que il faut pas oublier qu'il y a en
même temps pendant deux processus
parallèles c'était aussi le donner ou
pas donner le statut de candidats de
l'Ukraine à la division de l'Union
européenne et exactement pendant la
première visite madame Colonna a reçu le
gouvernement ukrainienne qu'il s'agit de
deux processus différents et c'est pas
du tout le blocage de la France de
l'école futur de l'Ukraine à l'Union
européenne merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous occupés
parce qu'il y a des bombardements à
Cardiff en ce moment donc bon courage
Helena à très vite bien sûr sur nos
antennes merci à vous tous nous avoir
suivis et rester avec nous sur France 24
[Musique]